move
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
mon petit doigt vient de me confier un
secret
il m'a dit nicolas et pimprenelle sont
allés se promener aujourd'hui dans la
campagne alors je descends vite les
voies car ils ont sûrement très faveur
mon échelle bros home pop et hip hop et
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits mon petit doigt m'a
dit que vous êtes allé à la campagne la
raison regarde parce que nous avons
quasi bon lebel
sans procès où la wii telle horreur
qu'est ce que tu as j'ai vu de là dans
le topic au
nom mais elle va me piquer et l'eau
chaude avec nous pas là que nous faisons
a booké
manger à quatre fleurs ou lever l'euro
aussi un 4 e fleur d'une chambre haute
en couleurs et quand la nuit est allé
dépôt le blues jouent quand la nuit y
ait de l'arrivée meyer feront danser
les foules mais ce n'est pas
fini avec après correction non 4
champignons non d'autres boutures ont
même mois les et mes yeux mes boutons de
rose dans ce tous les cadres andreu un
livre merveilleux comme le seuil élevé
le projet
continue dans l'art osé porter le voile
et le bar bouger pour le reste la
journée il
essayez
couler ce tour allons allons
aller et là elle est partie en voit on
retourne à la coopec ruf je n'en peux
plus c'est que granby notre poser groupe
heureux on va s'coucher tout seul bonne
nuit mais peu
non star bien
[Musique]
et
bravo nicolas
bravo pimprenelle vous avez fait un très
joli bouquet il n'y a pas d'odeur chez
vous pas trop non tu peux remonter sans
crainte nounours leggett ne pique que
sont les taquine
allons en route courageux compagnon en
route
bonne nuit des enfants fait deux tours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin les enfants on fera ce que je suis
content à toi et pourquoi nounours mais
deux petits amis sont sages ce soir ils
ne font pas de bruit ils sont sûrement
en train de travailler ce cher petit
jeter son lait voir mon échelle
au banc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou coup je peux entrer
[Musique]
bizarre
oui
qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est-ce que
vous cachez
vous rangez petit coquin vous fouillez
dans le sac de votre maman oui non m
oui
oh vous savez que ce n'est pas bien ce
que vous faites il ne faut pas ou
peu de choses
une houppette
ce qu'elle sent bon
ne soyez pas indiscret les enfants et ça
qu'est ce que c'est c'est pour faire du
feu c'est un briquet ni kayhan que de
bouchra
après un succès mais tu ne perds mes
mots forts elle mange des bonbons votre
gros nanar
voilà ce sont des clés soit c'est
sabrina avait été de foot et les enfants
c'est très vilain jeu voulu nous allons
remettait tout dans le sacrifice
moi je mets en sus une fleur d'un chat
de maman et je dirais que je vais bien
rangée et moi
et je dirais que j'ai des décalages et
son sac et moi bergen ça ne fait rien on
lui dira que c'est toi qui a fouillé
dans le sac les polices ou que ce
qu'elle va penser de moi c'est un beau
[Musique]
t'inquiète pas ne nous aime bien maman
sevrin leur maman là c'est un leurre
bonne nuit lezons feront de nuit de
noces à demain
[Musique]
allez vite vous couchez les petits et
surtout ne faites pas comme nounours
nicolas et pimprenelle
c'est très vilain de fouiller dans le
sac de sa maman
n'est ce pas nounours nous avons fait de
rougemont trop
oliva allons en route gros curieux ont
route bonne nuit les enfants peuvent de
boer heures
[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants
notre nounours est très mystérieux ce
soir au 1o diop qu'est ce qui est si
drôle de nouveau fait la farce que j'ai
préparé pas trop
ce soir vous allez tous être attrapé
mon échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop
je suis sûr qu'il est en retard os non
non ça va
quant à oullins 17
non c'est une bonne lan ou votre héros
créés
qu'est-ce que jouer les mannequins vous
trop bavard mais pas non plus en fait
non madame elle est occupée vous voulez
peut-être ont acheté quelques branches
non madame maman ne veux pas qu'on
laisse entre les gens qu'on ne connaît
pas il joue tellement je me battais
je voulais montrer moment aux tenues
regardez
ce qu'est ce génie
[Musique]
voulait pas beaucoup mon petit garçon
j'ai dit non c'est non et les russes
vous pouvez la garder mais gentil de
massage
mais si chacun fait moi fois votre main
[Musique]
que jolie main vous êtes une enfant
peureuse oui
ils vous ouvrent petit garçon fait
m'avoir votre mot non je ne fais rien
voir du tout eh bien je m'en vais vous
dire
pourquoi mon petit
local
au
double visite du musée
ça alors
ce mois
ou
aux humains
china growth and
[Musique]
co se
suffisent plus ce que je suis con trôle
mollo soi que je suis content pour une
fois je vous ai plein du
travail entre alba
[Musique]
d'accord je vous laisse toutes les
affaires de bolden sur lathan
tout beau cheval mon collier et les
boucles d'oreilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paul ii le zoo en
lui farceur de nounours oui madame la
bohémienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tu t'es bien amusés aux
autres au crumble force il ne m'avait
pas reconnu le cher petit au feu allant
en route mon bon ne nous route maubon
pas trop allez vite vous coucher les
enfants n'oubliez pas de faire votre
toilette du feu deux bouts re
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants notre petit nuage
vous amène ce soir un jardinier c'est le
beau temps patron qui me donne envie de
faire du jardinage et bien bon courage
nounours et mes deux petits amis vont
muter ce qu'on va s'amuser on le sol est
bon hop hop hop hop hop hop comme
vous soir la petite maisonnée
ce soir les enfants nous allons faire du
jardinage et je suis le jardinier qui
fait gagner un jardinier c'est un
monsieur qui plante des fruits des
fleurs et des légumes
oui de petits pois deschamps oui aussi
et vous savez vous planter le chou
savez-vous planter du chou à la mode à
la mode savez vous planter les choux à
la bonne note de g
je vais vous expliquer et vous chanter
avec moi
on les plante avec le doit à la mode à
la mode
savez-vous planter les choux à la botte
de pas la mode ça ne vous paraît ainsi à
la mode de chez nous à vous de chanter
les enfants
avec le plus
[Musique]
à
la mode la mode de celui de total sont à
la mode de l'humour avec la main
[Musique]
savez-vous planter sont à la mode à la
mode ça nous vous planter l'essai à la
mode de chez nous avec le
[Musique]
savez vous planter à la mode à la mode
ça me fait encore nice à la mode de chez
mac do
on les plante avec le couteau à la main
de la motte euro/litre atteint déclame
vague de chez soi
la volonté
de tous
film jardinage mais ce que ça donne
chaud je vais chercher un verre dans nos
sources c'est très gentil mais il est
grand temps d'aller rouge tient à 9
merci nicolas
haut ce que ça fait du bien
mais où sont-ils dont parle c
mes
enfants exemple non non tu sais pas quoi
dont nicolas
les plaines de jeu des blacks aux
jeunes sont je suis en retard bonne nuit
les petits
petits grand jardinier fanny
[Musique]
connu les enfants fait comme nicolas et
pimprenelle
allez vite vous couchez fait de porc
allons vite beaucoup celle où aussi
patron les travaux manuels sa fatigue en
route jardiniers boonen le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mon petit doigt
vient de me dire un secret
le nom ne durera pas trop il m'a dit
qu'il fallait que tu descendent vite
chez nicolas et pimprenelle plein sur
qu'aux jeux de son monster europe
pompoko
[Musique]
mon petit doigt m'a dit que nicolas et
pimprenelle vont faire une belle
surprise à nounours mais
bon score le petit
[Musique]
le cho lee flore et voilà aussi une
belle image pour toi on veut je suis
battu mon dieu je t'ai pas ma femme
c'est tout à fait c'est parce qu'on
t'aime c'est pour te faire plaisir ce
qu'ils peuvent être gentil quand il le
bol assieds toi et écoute c'est aussi
pour ça plaisir au co comment ça
commence pas prenez la cigale la cigale
et la fourmi la cigale et la fourmi
la cigale ayant chanté
tout l'été se trouva fort dépourvue
quand la bise fut venue pas un seul
petit morceau de mousse ou de vermisseau
le prouve hélas la crier famine chez la
fourmi sa voisine la priant de lui
prêter quelques grappes pour subsister
jusqu'à
jusque jusqu'à la saison nouvelle je
vous ferai lui dit-elle avant nous foi
d'animal intérêt et principal pas moi la
fourmi n'est pas prêteuse
c'est là son moindre défaut
que saviez vous ôte un show dit elle
c'est un peu plus au temps chaud ne vous
déplaise je chantais à tout venant vous
chantiez je suis forte s et bien dansez
maintenant
ah la la voilà je danse madame 9,8 red
bull l'enfant bravo vous en savez de
jolies choses maman qui ne l'a appris si
tu faible et on l'a prise pour toi la
femme je la raconterai à m'élever merci
mes chers petits
bagnis enos je vous accompagne non on va
se coucher tout seuls comme des grands
oh
bonne nuit mon école a fait pour être un
prenait
[Musique]
alors tu es content de norfolk patron
ils sont trop mignons
si nous leur faisions une grande
surprise
des coûteux
c'est une très bonne idée ils vont être
tellement content
route nounours ni les enfants fait pour
eux
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis pour se voir
nicolas soir 4 e mail bonsoir les neveux
nounours bulls veulent vite jeu verra
tous les voir mais ne veut pas trop
allons-nous nours ne soit pas un tonton
inquiet je ne suis pas inquiet ils sont
tellement sage c'est parce que je les
aime tout simplement les pom pom pom pom
pom boy
alors ces voitures accords passés
qui te tends fine et au repas nous
allons le trouver nous ton petit frère
bonsoir la grande famille
où mais je vois que mes neveux ont bon
appétit et mon petit score d'un petit
oscar
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pas preneur ou et au score
[Musique]
bonjour oui mon petit ange d'hossegor
ils courent toute la journée à quatre
pattes photo a derrière lui est
ce normal ça les bp ça court toujours à
cas pas seulement il fallait le
surveiller j'aurais voulu d'ivoire toi
de nous à fallon
cherchons oscar
oscar
mon chéri bien dire bonsoir à tonton
ce cas
je
viens dire bonsoir attentons tu parles
pas au score
toronto est la
coucou
le côté
oui tu
h 15 j'ai mis
quelques années
au score ou la table beaucoup
[Musique]
mangé
sous la table j'en suis sûr halo jaune
des voyous
bientôt on va se fâche
voyons ce n'est plus l'heure de juin
un dodo et même du trajet à 6 heures
comme les bébés
comme ça on pourra s'amuser ensemble
bonne nuit les oursons
nous danserons si vous vous eh oui dany
boon hui tous mes enfants
là j'ai tanner
à 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression que ce petit ange
d'oscar donne bien du souci à notre
nounours je te comme lui quand j'étais
petit patron il me ressemble
il est 6 millions à non en route mon
mignon nounours au
poteau bonne nuit des enfants faites de
beaux rêves
red bull
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir les enfants morts chaude au ballon
tu veux de popolo et oui nous avons ce
soir un vrai marchand de ballons je ne
vivent pas patron jeu layton ils sont
paumés neveu
pour nicolas pour pimprenelle et pour
tous mes amis et
voilà
on les jeunes hommes
c'est soit tu fais de mon petit oscar et
ne perd pas marchand de ballons
bonsoir les enfants qui veut de ballons
rouges
jali bien allons à l'eau ne vous
bousculez pas les enfants une minute
voilà le plus beau un pur au score c'est
bien agréable d'être un bébé tu te
trouves pas d'auto voilà pour pape rhône
el lobo le
merci non chérie pour nicolas legros
l'écart est bien le manque sa lutte pas
première est pour vous mes chers neveu
tenu
du passé à présent mais le veut vous
allez montrer à nicolas y apprenait ce
que votre oncle vous a appris à faire
avec des ballons
un peu
étroit
sur la terre
c'est pas mal bravo les enfants
attendus ce n'est pas fini 1 2 3
sous le nez
du dos
attendez attendez un deux trois
sur l'horreur
au
saut alors c'est vraiment calé à huy
bateau non on lui
famille tu viens pas bredel
[Musique]
au monde et on lire
bonne nuit non à guy bono ni les petits
là j'ai tant la lune
adomos
animé qu'à la fête pourrait pas prône l
[Musique]
dépêche-toi nounours nous sommes en
retard voilà voilà pas trop or quelle
belle soirée ne fait pas tant de bruit
tout notre petit monde dort déjà
où il y va
bonne nuit des enfants fait deux pour un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avoir des enfants
j'espère que vous êtes aussi sage que
les neveux nounours or vous avez vu
patrons ceux qui sont gentils et bien de
vue ah oui ce sont des hors sont
exemplaires je t'avouerai même que je
suis très étonné de nours moi aussi pas
trop je descend vite les embrasser ce
cher petit mot lynchage
[Musique]
coucou mon petit oscar
allons ferry fier
aucun gros chagrin la non ne pleure plus
voilà temps en temps bonsoir mais que se
passe tu as car un gros chagrin nous il
a peut-être fin non ils ont bien son
troisième but gros lot l'eau c'est
peut-être sa maman qui m'a mais oui ce
sens le petit amour allons console toi
nous allons téléphoné à maman et nous
irons bientôt la voir à temps numéro
raimu faut
nous allons téléphoné à ma mort à
sa salle vas-y à reno
allô
allô allô
qui est à l'appareil c'est moi nounours
c'est toi et millions bonsoir chers
frères comment vos mes petits très bien
même il ya alors très bien
ils sont un peu inquiets car ils n'ont
pas eu de tes nouvelles j'ai été fort
occupés j'ai refait les peintures oh tu
acheté une voiture j'ai refait les
peintures oh tu as fait des constitue au
lard effet les peintures on entend très
mal je te passe les petits
ou
totaux j'espère que tu es sage comme une
image emilia ta maman tu embrasses mon
petit rémy vous me manquez vous savez
l'enfant chéri revient vite il va
bientôt revenir vous voir madame emilia
bon chemin la gamme emilia bonsoir
nicolas bonsoir un problème le coût de
biens et millions
aux carmes petit poulet en nounours
choléra mendy demain emilia bonsoir je
t'embrasse
bonsoir je vous embrasse tous
[Musique]
bonsoir madame et médias ont soir
moins cher soit
quelques heures d'or
mais où sont ils tous passer ma parole
ils sont couchés
[Musique]
bonne nuit
trop tentant bonne nuit maisons font là
j'éteins la lune
7pour
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons en route nounours il est tard tu
es trop bavard au téléphone aux
marcheurs venus là je tente choses à lui
dire tu n'es lui dira demain bonne nuit
les enfants allez vite vous couchez
embrasser bien fort vos parents et fuck
de boer
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir des enfants bon sens
dépêche-toi nounours tu es ne veut
attendre je crois qu'ils sont impatients
de retourner chez leur maman je descends
les chercher patron
ma soeur emilia ce qu'elle va être
content bon l'échelle et hop hop hop hop
hop hop
funky
fin tu es prêt je trouve qu'elles sont
bien vite passer vos vacances la
prochaine fois vous restera plus
longtemps bonsoir les enfants alors une
petite voix d'or et au
score
oukil déléguons
le joli nous six mois
elle va être contente sa maman
cher rubina
tient un ours tués d'un drap ses fleurs
de notre part attaché à sa merci des
enfants des sources ont prôné le flanc
[Musique]
voilà et pourquoi pas pr mail
mongi à quatre fleurs bleues aux
quatre fleurs géantes aux couleurs à la
guitare et des 11 7e le losc aurait
grillé d'agréer mes quatre affaires dont
tu as fait tu vois que ça fait quel
effet tout
monsieur webb ont
défini des quatre commissions n'ont
d'autres champignons non cote robot
tueur on
met mois et les haies messieurs ne
boudons de rose dans ce tous les cadres
andreu à rigaud temps merveilleux quand
le sommeil élevé de thon rouge de
l'atlantique menées dans la rosée
portail des fois débarbouillé
journée il est mort
oui
hollande ne vous en route pour voir les
hauts-fonds
les oursons à bientôt lannoy enfin mon
petit casse car c'est un beau voyage
[Musique]
elle est toute fille de la maison ce
soir on leur creux de revenir bonnut et
pimprenelle
la nuit qui ferait encore bien
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
allons ne soyez pas impatients
le vent est bon nous allons très vite
arrivée chez maman emilia route ball
dealeuse au fond bonne nuit fais deux
bouts rêve
[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis beauceron
petit
nicolas et pimprenelle ont été très
sages tous ces jours ci aux oublis potro
est bien pour les récompenser nounours
leur a apporté un superbe bouquet de
fleurs il va leur raconter l'histoire de
ce bouquet oui je veux bon le seul
coup
les voilà bonsoir les enfants
s'étaient déjà je vous ai apporté des
fleurs
tenue
avec keyyo excellente idée et moi je
vais vous raconter comment est venu le
premier bouquet de fleurs là je match
loi
il ya très très longtemps
vivre est une petite fille qui
s'appelait kazuko tous des noms c'était
une petite japonaise elle habitait avec
sa maman madame ça que jaka une jolie
petite maison en bois et en papier elle
est mignonne mais là tout ici c'était
une petite japonaise
sa maman lui disait souvent que zookd
uni va jouer avec tes petites amies va
ramasser des coquillages au bord de la
mer mais la petite fille de voulait elle
préférait rester dans son jardin pour
s'occuper de ses amis l'aient fleuve
c'est un jardin sans terre et elle les
appelait chacune par leur nom bonjour
d'iris bonjour rose
bonjour lotus
bonjour glycines move les taillis et
toutes les fleurs était si contente
qu'elle répondait bonjour
kazuko to me mais voilà qu'un acte 1
kazuko toumi ne vint pas dans le jardin
les fleurs était triste et très inquiète
que se passait-il s'était pas réveillée
elle était partie un voyage all où elle
vit rentrer dans la maison un monsieur
habillé en noir très pressés qui porte
un une serviette de cui
chacun un docteur elle était malade oui
elle était malade très malade
et quand le docteur partie de la maison
la maman de kazuko to me madame sac et
jaka se mit à pleurer
alors toutes les fleurs du jardin
crieur ensemble nous voulons voir kozuka
to me nous voulons voir cause ou kotomi
madame sac et jaka les ententes elle
cueilli toutes les fleurs qu'elle
pouvait porter car tout voulait aller
voir
kozuka to be et quand la petite fille
vit entrer dans sa chambre sa maman avec
ses chers fleurs elle fut toute heureuse
et elle dit il faut vite les mettre dans
un vase plein d'eau car elles ont soif
le bouquet
venait d'honneur
[Musique]
c'était le premier bouquet oui le
premier
alors qu zuko tommy déry très vite en
compagnie de ses amis les fleurs lors
des joutes une eau à boire oui et elles
vécurent ensemble très heureuse pendant
toute la durée de sa convalescence
après après kazuko toumi a toujours
soigné ses amis les fleurs avec amour
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
au lit
[Musique]
je sois émir est toujours bien mais
flers elle était très jolie ton histoire
maintenant tu nous auras contrat encore
oui les enfants
là
j'éteins la lumière
bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
vous avez aimé l'histoire que vous a
raconté une source
oui eh bien allez vite vous coucher à
présent on y voit pas trop oui en route
mon cher nounours bonne nuit les enfants
fait de pour eux
[Applaudissements]
à l'auteur
devant vraie voiture
bonsoir les enfants notre nounours et de
joyeuse humeur ce soir je suis toujours
je vois vue lorsque je vais voir mes
petits amis patrons m'ont le cheval hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop bon combo
capable nicolas ça c'est une bonne
cachette
oh oui il nous trouvera pas
bonsoir la compagnie
il n'y a personne
je suis sûr qu'ils me font une blague
plus de petits coquins ils ne doivent
pas être cachés bien loin
[Musique]
où sont ils
les garnements ils sont sous la table
ballon sortait je vous ai vu petit
c'était bien que j'ai dit et tu nous as
pas trouvé non je ne vous ai pas trouvé
allons les petits il est tard
monsieur non non tu es bien bon
avec tous les petits garçons
avec les petites îles aussi nous nous y
tuaient gens qui m'ont
dit notre série
or vous le faites aux gros plaisir
alors je vais vous dire
voilà c'est simple tout bonnement
j'adorerais en
font
ils mettent donc à lui
grâce à maintenir un ami
nîmois nous nourrir quand tu reviens
bientôt j'espère bien
oui nous nous serions
je viendrai trop haut
[Musique]
devis chrono et des mères bonne nuit les
petits
la jettent à la rue bien
fait deux tours
[Musique]
oh
bonne nuit les petits faites comme vos
amis nicolas et pimprenelle allez vite
vous coucher mais n'oubliez pas de faire
votre toilette et de bien vous l'a vu le
dos embrasser bien fort vos parents du
feu de pour eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin les enfants bow wow on se croit
pas trop je descends vite chez mes deux
petits jeunes tu es bien pressé nounours
nous allons jouer ensemble ce qu'on va
s'amuser
je peux à lui patron wynn worth mais ne
vous disputez pas juif aux dont le seul
tort
au
bout ce soir les enfants ça à la joue
oui on joue à quoi
allah tout et au non au nom c'est nous
faisions une petite partie porridge
qu'est-ce qu'elle serait un jeu de
cartes pour jean disparus n'ont alors
plus forte afin que le chat à quoi on
joue alors j'ai une bonne idée en fait
oui
oui on joue mal c'est amusant ça très
amusant
tu vas faire voilà jeudi des noms
d'animaux et vous devez lever le doigt
pour la pac lorsque c'est un animal pour
quelque chose qui peut voler et c'est
hyper ip un gage use alors si je sens
que je vais être un pigeon
était trompé à gages bon si on veut
[Applaudissements]
nous je n'ai pas levé ma patte oui mais
non c'est toi nicolas c'est pas vrai pas
normal c'est pas moi c'est pas beau et
riche haineux et à lever des dates non
et puis moi je ne joue plus avec vous
non eh bien tu vas payer dégage non je
ne peux rien du tout car j'ai gagné moi
voilà patron javel
excusez moi les enfants mon patron me
réclame
tu sais pas malheureux moi qu'avec à nu
allons je vous accompagne ou non alors
on y va tout seul nom celui
de toute façon je n'ai rien compris à ce
jeu
on aurait mieux fait de jouer en
barriques
[Musique]
d'ennuyer enfants à
te voilà gros traînards vous n'êtes pas
gentilles potro je suis à peine
descendue chez nicolas et pimprenelle
que vous m'a plu avec votre pipeau il
est tard nounours les petits enfants
doivent aller se coucher et il faut que
tu montrent le bon exemple
bon jusque vous le dites voulons en
route bourse en dormez vous bien
sagement les enfants du fait pour eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
avez vous été sage aujourd'hui trois
sages patron je vole haut carotti alors
vous allez tous chanté ensemble une
chanson très amusante je sais laquelle
patron je descend vite la proposer à
nicolas ya patronale mon échelle ap ap
ap ap
[Musique]
bongo lors d'attenté comme je joue bien
tu es très doué mais où est pas preneur
j'arrive moi ça vaut de noces regarde
comme j'ai les mains propres je viens de
me laver et moi qui végète à la toilette
et bien puisque vous êtes aussi sage
nous allons chanter à trois fois et nous
chantons frère jacques
toi nicolas tu nous accompagne au piano
pas preneur banque lui tout seul
ensuite vous chanter tous les deux et on
finit tous les trois attention
frère jacques frère jacques
dormez vous
dormez vous savez les matines sa
thématique dont gabon d'un cadeau à
votre micolon frère jacques frère
jacques frère majorque
dormez vous
chagrine sonnés les matines zone amado
dingsdag ton temps
avec nous frères jacques frère jacques
baudou modano
du bol
encore une fois
de plus en plus doucement
[Musique]
frère
abou sow des moteurs sonne les matchs de
nom d'une tonne
à long ou lui
ou
au
millénaire bonsoir les petits la jette à
la lune
fait pour
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo les enfants vous avez très bien
chanté moi aussi je chantais pas trop
vous ne m'avez pas entendu bravo mon
gros nounours tu as très bien chanté
aussi
allons en route fidèle compagnon en
route mon bon pas trop
bonne nuit fait peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les enfants bonsoir les
hauts-fonds bon le seul et didon
nounours tu es bien pressés ou dix
patrons mais deux petites amies
m'attendent et je sais qu'ils m'ont
préparé une surprise alors dépêche-toi a
tout de suite propos
moi je suis les professeurs et moi la
lèves tu dois répondre à mes questions
après j'ai vomi bonjour madame tel
arrêté il est midi qui vous l'a dit la
petite forêt ou doc était à la chapelle
qu'est ce que lui fait de la dentelle
pour ti corps le dame de paris qui
portent des souliers gris ouvre moi les
petits les fenêtres
d'agos la plus belle la plus belle papon
de la bulle et
au soir le petit dans un immense tu fais
pas tu dis ça vous paraît
on en sait plusieurs
assiettes et écoute celui de la souris
verte
je suis tout ouïe l'eau une souris verte
qui courait dans l'herbe
je l'attrapé par là que je la montre a
fait messieurs ces messieurs mais 10h30
péladeau lui le groupe est là dans l'eau
sarver rennes escargots touchant bravo
les enfants que c'est joli on te dira
encore des autres et maintenant les
petites souris
l'ennui chronos bonne nuit mon cher
petit là
j'éteins la lumière
7pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours et cette surprise nicolas
et pimprenelle mon resitue un groupe a
pas trop ils en savent des choses aux la
pruche allons en route oui on route
vivement les vacances pas trop qu'on se
repose un peu oui nounours bonne nuit
les enfants allez vite vous couchez
embrasse bien fort votre papa eu votre
maman
c'est deux pour un
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]